ces images inédites obtenu par
l'émission enquête ont été captées il ya
quelques mois à l'école polytechnique de
montréal
on a testé la résistance de cinq
suspendus bond vers la poste à québec
qui ont été retirés au cours des deux
dernières années une demande du
ministère des transports au fur et à
mesure que la charge augmente on peut
entendre des fiches d'assez kick ass
jusqu'à la rupture du câble plusieurs
câbles testé en laboratoire avaient
perdu plus de la moitié de la résistance
d'origine jusqu'à 57% le père résultats
obtenus depuis qu'on a commencé ses
tests en 2015 les 160 suspentes du pont
pierre laporte sont composés de deux
câbles verticaux chacune elles servent à
retenir le tablier du pont les câbles
sont tellement difficiles à inspecter
que c'est impossible de connaître leur
état réel sans les enlever
mais les récents tests et les dernières
inspections le confirme ces câbles sont
de plus en plus rouillé je dirai qui et
23h59 plus haut de corrosion plus avoir
accéléré le phénomène donc un moment
donné on perd un peu de contrôles un
ingénieur bien au fait de la situation
s'inquiète un visiblement le message
serait en pole parce que si le message
je rendais on n'en serait pas là nous
avons eu quelques rencontres mais il a
refusé toute entrevue à la caméra nous
avons accepté de protéger son identité
parce qu'il craint de subir des
représailles
le problème c'est que les choses
avancent pour irriguer qui prévu encore
pour le remplacement complet des
suspentes à court terme certains câbles
du pont pierre laporte sont en si
mauvais état qu'ils pourraient céder à
tout moment selon nos informations
camion lourd 20 et tremblement terre
peuvent affecter suspentes déjà affaibli
par la corrosion imagine une suspens qui
mesurent plusieurs dizaines de mètres
qui s'est depuis qu'il tombe sur des
voitures en bois sans compter le risque
de rupture un cascade
si on avait le malheur qui est deux ou
trois suspende côte à côte qui avait
perdu la moitié de leur résistance on
pourrait avoir cet effet deux nous
visiblement notre lanceur d'alerté n'est
pas le seul à s'inquiéter enquête a mis
la main sur un récent rapport signé par
deux ingénieurs du ministère des
transports ils décrivent il faut
absolument éviter la rupture de nous de
plusieurs suspentes avec comme finalité
peu probable mais potentiel une
catastrophique rupture en cascade
pouvant ultimement causé l'effondrement
de l'ouvragé
invité à commenter nos révélations le
ministère des transports nous a offert
une entrevue avec celui qui coordonne et
planifie les travaux du pont pierre
laporte au courant de ce rapport le
malaise est au courant vous êtes
responsable du pont la peur puis il ya
des ingénieurs du ministère qui ont fait
un rapport de plus avantage sur les
systèmes de suspension ben on savait
qu'il y avait un rapport global sur la
gestion des ouvrages qui s'en venait
mais on les fait des suspensions mais on
savait pas qu'il y avait urgence en la
demeure comme vous le le rapport a été
déposé le 21 avril à des gestionnaires
et des hauts fonctionnaires du ministère
les auteurs recommandent le remplacement
complet des suspentes le plus tôt sera
le mieux certaines doivent l'être à
court terme pour éviter les
remplacements en urgence ou des impacts
importants au niveau de l'exploitation
du port je sers mercier et son équipe
s'appuie sur l'expertisé d'une firme
américaine qui mène des tests
supplémentaires sur les suspentes les
thèses restent ans à polytechnique ça a
été fourni à notre expert moi je peux
pas tirer de conclusion je prends un
expert en confiance on va avoir des
recommandations dans les prochaines
semaines on suit les recommençants
conçoit on n'a pas eu de recommandation
qu'il fallait remplacer les suspentes à
très court terme nos experts s'entendent
pour dire que pour l'instant la
situation est stable sous contrôle dans
un monde idéal on serait même déjà en
travaux ailleurs dans le monde dès qu'on
découvre dû cependant nos magie on va
commencer le remplacement de toutes les
suspendre plusieurs ponts suspendus à
travers le monde ont subi un premier
remplacement complet de suspentes avant
leurs 50 ans le pont pierre laporte lui
à 50 12
jusqu'à maintenant on change les
suspentes lorsqu une inspection visuelle
en démontre l'urgence seulement 15 ont
été remplacés à ce jour si on n'agit pas
atteint il pourrait être trop tard trop
temps veut pas nécessairement dire que
le pont sera montré dans le fond du
fleuve mais on peut pas se permettre de
le fermer plusieurs semaines ce serait
impensable parce que selon plusieurs
experts la rupture d'une seule suspentes
forcerait la fermeture du pont le temps
d'inspecter toute la structure ce qui
pourrait prendre plusieurs jours ou même
des semaines et les impacts serait
majeure plus de 125 mille véhicules
franchissent le pont pierre laporte
chaque jour c'est le seul lien
permettant aux camions lourds de
traverser le fleuve à l'est de
trois-rivières aussi mis la tête dans le
sable et quelques années en se disant il
commence à y avoir un problème mais je
veux pas le voir je vais attendre d'être
vraiment rendu au problème pour le
régler en 2018 le mtq a annoncé le
remplacement de cette suspens pour les
tester on n'est pas à remplacer des 160
suspens tc pas de travaux qu'on pourrait
juger urgent
pourtant des échanges de courriels
obtenus par enquête nous apprennent que
depuis 2016 des ingénieurs du mtq
martèle qu'il faut planifier le
remplacement de toutes les suspentes
pour éviter les travaux d'urgence on
venait de remplacer les deux premières
suspens sur le pont pierre laporte
l'une d'elles avait perdu près de 40% de
sa résistance d'origine à sochaux
coureurs étaient dans les échanges de
courriels
avec le temps les suspentes ont continué
de se dégrader tellement qu'on a dû
procéder à des remplacements d'urgence
l'automne dernier pendant des semaines
la voie de droite a été interdite aux
camions lourds dans les deux directions
pour éviter de surcharger le câble
endommagé aux besoins aussi on a
remplacé des suspentes on pourra le
faire des contrats qui sont encore en
cours de signature les des commandes ou
six ont lancé tous se fait évidemment
pour assurer la sécurité du public
assurer la pérennité de l'ouvragé notre
lanceur d'alerté estime qu'il faudrait
avoir changé toutes les suspentes du
pont pierre laporte et d'ici quatre ou
cinq ans maximum et quoi votre stratégie
c'est quoi le plaindre en plasma contre
moi je développe pas de plan de
remplacement je vais je vais faire enfin
qu'on selon les recommandations des
experts à l'inter nos ministères et des
experts à l'externe le ministère des
transports prévoit faire le remplacement
complet des suspentes sur un horizon de
5 à 15 ans même si dans leur récent
rapport les ingénieurs écrivent que la
rapidité avec laquelle les dommages
progresseront est quasi impossible à
estimer la gestion du risque de rupture
de suspentes n'est pas acceptable sur
une longue période
de quoi on a besoin de plus pour aller
de l'avant avec un plan de remplacement
complet on veut savoir la durée de vie
de suspens donc ça on veut on veut
connaître par lesquels suspends ton
commence quelle part qu'elle suspend ton
va commencer pour qu'elle supplante on
peut on doit on doit terminer
combien de temps on a notre source
aurait pu se tourner vers l'ordre des
ingénieurs ou se prévaloir de la loi
protégeant les lanceurs d'alerté mais
ils doutent de l'efficacité et de la
confidentialité du processus j'ose
espérer que juste en voyant ce qu'ils
vont sortir dans le reportage de
gouvernement vont réagir puis qui va
dire mettons le pied sur l'accélérateur
il s'y marie pierre bouchard radio
canada à québec pour l'émission enquête